le gros des troupes s'est retrouvé pour
les manifestations en début d'après-midi
à Blois des 10 heures ce matin à Tours
ils étaient entre 10 et 12000 abattre le
pavé au lendemain de la locution
d'Emmanuel Macron qui a semble-t-il
raviver les braises de leur colère la
réforme est passée les manifestants
gardent et espoirs que la rue puisse
faire plier tout de même le gouvernement
Faustine lune
près de 10000 manifestants à Tours selon
la police 12000 selon les syndicats pour
cette 9e journée de mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites au sein du
cortège beaucoup de colère en
particulier contre la manière dont a été
adopté le texte
on est là entre le tenue démocratique
contrôle
moi je veux crier je veux montrer ma
colère et que je ne suis pas du tout
contente de ce qui se passe je
m'attendais aussi au 49.3 mais il faut
pas me prendre pour une imbécile à un
moment donné donc je cette arme-là de
pouvoir manifester faire la grève et je
vais en profiter manifester et faire
grève toujours la même méthode à
toujours ou très peu de débordements ont
été recensés depuis janvier ont mis sur
la contestation pacifique pour se faire
entendre on y croira toujours parce
qu'autrement si on n'y croit plus je ne
sais pas ce qu'on peut faire
je sais rien faire de la violence mais
c'est pas le principe donc
continuellement continuellement jusqu'où
ce sera possible peut-être qu'à un
moment donné
faudra qu'il accepte aussi que que ça
dégénère c'est de sa faute en grande
partie c'est à faute du gouvernement
mais mais j'espère dans un premier temps
que les manifestations pacifistes c'est
notre pouvoir c'est notre droit
fondamental et donc
j'espère que que ça va plus marcher
j'ai terminé même si la réforme a été
adoptée elle n'est pas encore entrée en
application alors pour les manifestants
l'objectif est désormais d'empêcher le
processus d'aller jusqu'au bout derrière
il va falloir qu'il promet que la loi il
va y avoir une saisine de conseil
constitutionnel et là en effet en ayant
autant de salariés et autant de secteurs
d'activités qui débroulée il faut avouer
que certains peuvent hésiter là-haut
donc le but du jeu nous aujourd'hui
c'est de leur faire la démonstration on
est encore très fort donc on peut encore
les faire reculer rien n'est acté après
un face à face avec la police sans
heurts devant la préfecture la
manifestation s'est terminée dans le
calme à Blois le cortège rassemblait
8000 personnes selon la police 10000
selon les syndicats